Lindsey me snapped in kindergarten if
asked why I became a Jesuit but I can
only say it's like with painting yeah
well I felt compelled to do it and you
been mine ultimately it was out of love
absolutely liebe let's take house leave
it I justice I be true in my last year
at school there were four subjects that
interested me philosophy theology
political science and journalism and I
asked myself in what profession could I
combine all for food coma in la fille de
studium state when I was at university I
decided to become a priest I got to know
the Jesuits and I was impressed by their
work I thought it would be a good group
in which to be a priest and the past 10
years have confirmed that when they
listen senior have this would be
statistic yep danged ethnic I thought I
should start with what seemed to be the
craziest option and if it didn't work
out I could always do something else
Oh
dead center datasets finding God in all
things is the core Jesuit spirituality
as that means not retreating behind the
walls of a monastery but reaching out to
the world with a positive attitude son
and I positivist suqian alphas evade
jesuits write the letters SJ after their
names indicating their members of the
society of jesus the term jesuit was
originally an insult implying people who
can't stop talking about Jesus but the
followers of st. Ignatius proudly
accepted the intended insult and carried
the name Jesus into the world as
missionaries and teachers scholars and
pastors with a strong hierarchical
structure they've also been called the
soldiers of Christ their aim to search
for God in all things and help others
father to be asked Zimmerman is the
rector of canisius colleague in Berlin
it's one of three high schools run by
the Jesuits in Germany when beginning
didn't one let's start the day by
singing a happy add my orem de gloria
gloria to the greater glory of God
Jesuits have been famous for their
school since the order was founded in
the 16th century it runs colleges and
universities around the world today
there are 17,000 Jesuits in 95 countries
suit Sita Caesar gesellschaft music
affair the official name Society of
Jesus means that we are his companions
our aim is to be available not just to a
local church or a particular region but
wherever we're needed Welton Adam
bouticks news I joined an international
order with the idea of perhaps working
in the field of international relations
of it but my superior said to me Berlin
is also important youth work is
important and he sent me to do you work
in Berlin don't have a human bed kamat
father jörg IELTS works in the southern
german city of nuremberg organizing
political campaigns to combat poverty in
the world he himself says he was 20 when
he discovered that God had plans for him
let's finish inside working with
asylum-seekers imports pork was a
watershed for me I saw how our wealthy
nation dealt with people who came to us
in need they didn't receive help but
were often treated worse than dogs Oh
Josh a phone I'm stopped and I realized
that I couldn't accept that especially
because the Jesuit Order sees faith and
justice as belonging together global
would ganesh catch tues a magazine be
animals Jesuits have the mission of
creating a more just world their faith
demands solidarity with the poor father
out says donating money to poor nations
as was done in the past is not enough he
spent many years researching the causes
of conflict and poverty in developing
nations and bringing them to the
attention of the German public
a sunday morning in the eastern german
city of lights ish father Clement
Blatter tis a university chaplain here
if I focus in fiat spa I was due to be
sent to Santo Domingo to work in a slum
for two years but then there was this
vacancy in Leipzig and my superior
decided that I was needed here it's a
clearance is pavan so that's how I
became university chaplain in 2009
student infer you just can't emotional
Shaolin about the strategies and
father blatter tis popular with the
students he sees his main task as
listening to them and helping them come
to terms with their lives that's his
vision of pastoral service one of the
Jesuits key activities Cesar gave it I
de familias I think of pastoral care as
giving people your time the common
finding time for the people who come to
you fit does and creating space for
their concerns against its you can't set
an agenda the students come with
whatever's on their minds giving
problems with their studies with their
relationships with faith doubts a very
wide range of issues by firm as a de
politicize reason cause while mass is
being celebrated in the chapel
volunteers prepare a midday meal about a
hundred people are expected father
Blatter says the spirit of freedom is
typically Jesuit no subject is taboo
even in questions of faith
the students are attracted to this
intellectual freedom many of them are
trying to make sense of their lives and
searching for faith wrestling with what
the church teaches and their own
understanding of the truth
you
dimes has had some distant Ahmad where I
come from people go to church out of
habit I have the feeling many of them
don't question their faith they go to
church because others go but here are
only people who believe go to church
I've met some who have a very deep faith
and that has impressed me yeah it's made
me question my own beliefs and discuss
them no rebounder said and religion has
become more important in my life we
still got the one father arts believes
that everybody has good and bad in them
which shapes their lives he says it's
important to focus on what's good who's
thinking either many shots I think
everybody has aspects with which God can
work with you Bob I didn't come bus but
me I've always believed that curiosity
is a very important quality to analyze
and understand the way the things are
connected that's why goethe's faust
means a lot to me mr. Faust is a
character who struggles to understand
what binds the world's innermost core
together a nobleman from the Basque
Country Ignatius of Loyola founded the
society of jesus in Rome in 1540 at a
time when the Catholic Church was
reeling from the effects of the
Protestant Reformation his aim was not
to turn his back on conflicts but to
embrace the world to secure it for God
he and his companions took a special
oath of loyalty to the Pope they were
prepared to be sent wherever they were
needed
473 years later in March 2013 a Jesuit
was elected Pope for the first time in
history with jorge bergoglio former
Archbishop of Buenos Aires the papacy
and the Vatican have adopted a new style
atelier sur la buona sera
she wouldn't let me see on floor I'm
surprised and delighted by his wisdom
Afghans I'd hug on the one hand he has
introduced changes and raised lots of
hopes but many people say it's all
talking symbols have to put it in Jesuit
terminology I think this man is setting
the scene for more mr. Sun and show
plots for mere bhai did with violence I
named art angst especially his lack of
inhibition his boldness in reaching out
to people i think this inner freedom is
typically Jesuit which is anybody
Tisha's any cause if I have this freedom
I can reach out to people without fear
you know be open to the difficulties
embrace problems in the church in suqian
of shirish chitin to gain of problems
Telamon into a shih tzu Kim if you leave
me relative schnell I feel very much at
home with empty cousin from tats demon
king but I think he'll also confront the
church with unfamiliar issues in your
pocket it's important not to create the
impression that we Jesuits monopolizing
first and foremost he's the Pope it's
not a Jesuit in his current job that's
important but we'll find him less
familiar when he speaks as a Latin
American about poverty and has a few
things to say to Europeans assignments
in March 2014 at the Jesuit mission in
Nuremberg yoke islets and the head of
the mission father Klaus fear Toyota
presented their latest book the ski
Toyota filing dog this is a good time to
sum up what Pope Francis has begun
changing in the church during the past
year let's consider his statement how I
would like a poor church for the poor
whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing whether it's disturbing or helpful
just what Stan should the church take on
poverty the two Jesuits have questioned
experts on the struggle against poverty
worldwide they've also asked poor people
themselves and come to the conclusion
that the church should retain its wealth
but use it to fight poverty but what is
for me I love getting out in the fresh
air when I'm not working I like to go
walking or hiking or do some gardening
somehow I feel closer to heaven then
ignatius of loyola wanted his companions
to look at the world attentively and
without bias and to find God there
together these two aspects create a
spiritual path one that Jesuits continue
to follow today it's the spirituality
that informs their lives their aim is to
open their senses to a deeper level of
reality chick-fil-a's Newton was on
unfold as this creation is not something
that happened in the past that's a
misconception of the ship for what God's
creation is continuous does high school
I mean you can see traces of God in His
creation you can find God in everything
but and what you can find in yourself if
you listen carefully is of course not
the voice of God but your own spiritual
life which is the result of God's
activity the eagle and dd5 it is you can
sense it it's like a stone falling into
water you may not see the stone but you
can see the ripples that the stone
causes with you beta leader Stein Marty
come on zine
tobias zimmerman is also pasta at the
maria regina motti avim church in berlin
the church is dedicated to the memory of
German Catholics who resisted the Nazi
ideology because of their Christian
faith and paid for that courage with
their lives some of them were Jesuits
rejection and death are part of this
world Jesuits have to accept that but
deeper than suffering is the knowledge
that God is to be found in all things if
only you are open to him and listen at
this mass fathered simmerman focuses on
the process of listening
the system munch my first ruined
sometimes it's unsettling in dyckman
guns and at the same time you discover
entirely new tones new harmonies one
sometimes you're reminded of something
from everyday life blood suddenly when
you walk through the world again later
and Here other sounds that's what it's
about it is that we let it take us there
to save her things that we let ourselves
be taking it into a meaning that doesn't
lie behind the things but on the surface
McGee and what we experience immediately
and what we see and hear what we sense
and feel that we experience the world is
being filled with a God whose seeps out
of the world's every pore I in Poland
fitted he's not in some kind of holy
shrine somewhere behind a curtain but
right there in the world that we
experience every day sona [ __ ] and
evade the UNC Aidan topic eating it
Tobias Timmerman is 47 he has long been
fascinated by the ideal of a life
dedicated to God he entered the Jesuit
Order 24 years ago he was an artist well
before that sadly stinker I've been
painting for as long as i can remember
who i was we have there was also a time
when i played music but I've always
painted I can't live without painting as
mine is for me not to beat for me it's a
kind of prayer but that's not
necessarily obvious in the paintings
themselves it's similar to the world
itself God can be found everywhere
whether that means that my pictures
don't have to be explicitly religious
unless I see team in Western Asia
explicite leaguers and for me
jesuits don't live in monasteries but in
communities
university chaplain Clemens Blatter
takes his turn at cocking like the other
four Jesuits with whom he lives as in
other religious orders Jesuits take vows
on becoming a member of the Society of
Jesus Jesuits promise obedience to the
Pope and to their superior they also
vowed chastity and to follow a simple
modest lifestyle when he hit semester
docked in park when I walk in the park
for instance I'm happy when I see young
families I women healthy man hours but
during my training it was a painful
thought of it oh man that I would never
have children of my own that is a
sacrifice yantis yourself and Fitz East
are however what I do now is so
fulfilling that I tell myself I can't
have everything I can't do everything
for me I'm happy for young families when
I see them and I go my own way and find
fulfillment there einen vehicle and find
it out in a few lunk
for many Jesuits the Spiritual Exercises
of st. Ignatius are the foundation of
their lives a set of meditations and
prayers that help you reach important
decisions by opening yourself to God
Clemens Blart also offers them to lay
people
the basic assumption is that God has a
special task for each of us here in live
t father Blatter has read a short
passage from the Bible come in on this
is a text Tilly I can imagine this
incident very clearly and with it I
named Jesse nuts be right I say what do
I see what do I hear basket for what's
happening here in this as a name and
what is my role in this scene invoice my
plots
he be fixed the most important spiritual
exercise for me was when as a
twenty-year-old novice I imagined
spending an afternoon together with
Jesus in Nazareth making tables and
Joseph's carpentry shop I was in the
back shot by fateh Yosef t-shirt swollen
Antilles and armed then in the evening
going swimming in a pond outside the
town and then having a meal that Mary
had made he's a guy in that spiritual
exercise in which I had the feeling that
I was really in Nazareth I realized that
Jesus was also a 20 year old ones and
thought about his vocation to preach and
proclaim the kingdom of God is this
something that I the 20 year old Jesus
must do or am I just fooling myself I
realized that Jesus was confronted with
much the same question as I was facing
as a young Jesuit and I sensed a
connection a bond and I felt that I was
following my own vocation my own path in
life together with him my number one
focus of mine and even speak ghia
recommend it snows balloons action I
didn't I spent the finals period of my
training in Los Angeles we were seven
guys from seven different countries from
Africa Asia Europe and America and I
discovered that we were very similar
because we were molded by these
exercises this attempt to follow Jesus
we thought the same way in spite of the
cultural differences
canisius college is still one of the
most respected high schools in Berlin in
spite of revelations about child abuse
in the past the Jesuits educational
ideals influence the life of the
students and they're using trizol an
oxide a Jesuit school should be a place
where students experience human dignity
sign a place where they experience
justice that means a place where their
human dignity is respected it should be
a place open to the question of God and
the school should be a place where
children are educated to help others
mention free under the escape you'll
admit that means a place where my own
career is not my only goal but where I
learned to value others in my life viet
always to have them as part of my plan
with dr. plans
vomits no it's at six in 1986 when I was
working with asylum seekers in boards
Borg and first came to the conclusion
that it's not enough to hand out
blankets and shoes but that we have to
change the political decisions that
underlie the problem my superiors told
me a Jesuit should not get involved in
politics but I was stubborn and after
the break through with the anti-landmine
campaign which the jesuit refugee
organization started in cambodia and
after we achieved an international
commission forbidding anti-personnel
mines and won the nobel prize other
Jesuits also began to realize that it's
a task that has to do with faith and
with justice so where does an abbott st
the world disabled it was my club or
garage cuts a tuna
the history of the Jesuit Order is long
and complex and there have been some
shameful chapters but the 20th century
saw a spectacular modernization which
some theologians view enthusiastically
others as merely following a fashion in
Africa and the United States the order
is growing whereas in Germany there's a
shortage of vacations here there are
only 350 Jesuits but they are all
committed to being companions of Jesus
indium was Brennan but you have to burn
with a flame that you want to pass on to
others feeling mention and I've met a
lot of people who have given me that
flamed they inspired me and I said to
myself I want to be somebody who is full
of fire dear minam foyer effort is der
heilige agostino services san agustin
says my heart is restless until it rests
in God finit and India since nearly
between years was it's about loving
Jesus confess being fascinated by his
life by his person and the desire to
follow him devil gene occifer the Jesuit
group at meijer once put it very
beautifully ever after value when asked
what Jesus meant to him he said
everything for the Alice that's a
wonderful answer that's because you have
to honor its Nick wasn't what whether
this was when as well I ain't losin away
let's see here
you